We learn the words monomial, binomial, and trinomial. So that way, we could talk
about polynomials. I'll be saying those words a lot. So I wanted to make sure
you're clear on them. For example, here we have a trinomial and another
trinomial. And we're going to try and add these together. Before we get started,
I'm going to show you some algebra tiles to help us think through this. Here's a
square, and each side of this square is x units in length. I don't know it. But
I do know that the area of the square is x times x, or x squared. This rectangle
has a legnth of one on one side, and x on the other. So the area of this
rectangle would just be x. And finally, this last tiny square, has an area of 1,
it's a 1 by 1 square. I drew these shapes out to help us think about like terms.
So let me show you what this problem would like, using these shapes. For this
first trinomial, I would have three x squared's, four x's, and 3, or three 1's.
You can see a similar representation for the second trinomial. So if you want to
add these two polynomials together, we want to combine the like terms. To add
like terms together, we simply add up the coefficients of the same term. So 3x
squared and 2x squared would make 5x squared. 4 x and 2 x would make 6 x's, and
3 and 1 would make 4. I can rearrange my terms in the first polynomial and the
second polynomial to get my like terms. Now that we have this, we're ready to
combine like terms. Here was the original problem, and if we're just adding we
can drop the parentheses and rearrange to find our like terms. So we have 5x
squared plus 6x plus 4. This is the trinomial we get when we add these two
together.